I'm dealing with stress affecting my immune system and digestion.
Stress affecting my immune system and digestion.
Would your new CBD product be good for this?
Well, CBD historically has been good for people with stress, because CBD can decrease
anxiety, but that's not on everybody.
So is there any downside to using CBD?
The answer is no, not really.
There's really no downside.
It's just that it's not guaranteed to work on everybody, but it's worth a try.
So trying CBD would be something I would think to give it a try.
Other things that can help with stress are adrenal support, adaptogens.
I would think those things maybe could help just as much or better, maybe a better chance
of helping.
If you have CBD at home, give that a try, you can certainly get some CBD and try that
as well.
Second part of this question.
Also, I am currently taking 20 milligrams a month to hold it three times a day.
How long do patients usually take this?
There's no downside to this.
So you can take this.
So taking higher dose, melatonin like this actually acts as an oxidizing agent to the cancer.
So don't stop taking this.
Just keep up on that.
So we'll probably won't change that very soon.